المملكه العربيه السعوديه وانا مراقب من
لهذا ال- ال- همم الجهود التي تبذلها
الحكومه السعوديه همم في همم في البيئه
بدات باعاده هيكله البيئه انشات وزاره
البيئه ثم بعد ذلك طرحه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من ضمن المسؤولياتها تجاه تخفيض
الانبعاثات همم وجزء من مساهمتها ضمن
تخفيض انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد الكربون في
الغلاف الجوي
والتزامها همم امام مؤتمر باريس توقيعها
على مؤتمر باريس واتفاقيه باريس لخفض
الانبعاثات والالتزام امام المجتمع الدولي
كجزء من مساهمتها في ذلك فطرحت عدد من
المبادرات من ضمن هذه المبادرات مبادره
الشرق الاوسط الاخضر ومبادره السعوديه
الخضراء وكل المبادرتين تمثل خمسه في
المئه من المساهمه العالميه يعني العالم
طرح في في هذا المؤتمر وما المؤ هي ليه اا
زراعه تريليون شجره الموجود حاليا في
العالم ثلاثه تريليون شجره حسب اخر دراسه
نشرت في هذا المجال في يعني ثلاثه مليون
فيض- يريدون يضيفون همم
تريليون من الاشجار همم مساهمه همم الشرق
الاوسط والمملكه العربيه السعوديه سوف
تكون 5% من الرقم العالمي هذه الاسهال
طبعا اذا اذا قرن همم في الاسهم في
الامتصاص من ثاني اكسيد الكربون وتخفيض
الانبيعات يعادل ما يعتقد انه طبعا هناك
مبادره اخرى من ضمن هذه المبادرات وهو
مسؤوليات الدول جميعا دول الاقليم في
تخفيض 6 ما يقارب ب 670 مليون طن مترين من
مكافاه ثاني اكسيد الكربون همم وقد اشارته
ولي العهد حفظ الله في ذلك في بدايه خطاب
الملكي في مبادره الشرق الاوسط في شرم
الشيخ هذه الم التي طرحت العام الماضي
انتقلت الى التطبيق على ارض الواقع فااه
شاهدنا في مؤتمر شرم الشيخ همم بدايه همم
هذه المبادره وعنون لها بالانتقال من
الطموح الى العمل فبدات تفعيل هذه
دوله عربيه مصر والجهه صاحبه المبادره
دوله عربيه السعوديه
في في الجزء الثاني وفي نسختها الثانيه
وبدايتها من جمهوريه مصر العربيه انا
اعتقد انها رساله همم في التعاون الاقليمي
وهو بدا الان فعليا ايضا مبادره همم
المملكه في همم انشاء المقر اللي مودرنه
الشرق الاوسط في الرياض